you requested it so here it is today I'm
going to share with you my very simple
hair care routine as well as how I have
cut and styled my own hair for over 10
years I want to preface this by saying
that I am not a professional hairdresser
I am just somebody who has completely
transformed the health of her hair to
what it is today hair that I love waking
up to so I hope that the tips that I
share with you are helpful but please
take it with a grain of salt everybody's
hair type is different hey everyone I'm
yesi and on this channel we talk about
minimalism and intentional living and
living a happier more fulfilling life
with less so if this sounds interesting
to you be sure to subscribe for more
videos if you like these so first of all
just to share with you the Journey of my
hair transformation back when I was in
high school was the first time that I
had tried out curling and straightening
my hair and I immediately became
addicted to it I loved it I would wake
up in the morning and curl and
straighten my hair all the time but it
got to a point where I had damaged my
hair so much that when I would step
outside the door on a humid day I could
literally feel my hair lifting as I was
walking out the door and here in this
Georgia weather it is humid a lot so
then what ended up happening is that
because I had damaged my hair then I
felt like I needed to curl or style it
in order to hide the damage that I had
caused until one day I decided that I
was done my hair was down to my hip at
that point and I'd cut it down to a
little bit below my shoulder and I also
vowed to myself that I was not going to
curl it or straighten it or use any kind
of heat tools for at least a year and at
that time for me this felt like it was a
huge undertaking and the things that I
did next really are what helped me to
just restore the health of my hair as a
matter of fact I currently don't even
own a hair curler a straightener a blow
dryer or any of those sorts of products
so this is truly very simple and
hopefully over a period of time you will
find that you will have hair that you
love waking up to hopefully my hair
doesn't look too crazy this morning but
the only thing that I have actually done
to it is apply this hair paste
this is actually John's hair paste
because I love to have his hair in the
executive hairstyle you know that
slipped back look but it's also really
helpful for me because I have a ton of
baby hairs after having given birth and
that's the only thing that I applied I
could totally do a hair gel or a
hairspray but because this is what I use
for him I am not about to go buy more
products I'm all about Simplicity and
keeping it simple this works for him it
works for me it's two for one and by the
way any of the products that I mentioned
that I used I will link down in the
description below but please don't feel
like you have to use these particular
products everybody's hairstyle is
different hair type is different and
what works for me may not work for you
okay so in reference to how I cut my
hair there are two different ways in
which I have cut my hair and one is just
the regular maintenance for my hair
basically trimming my ends and then the
other is what I do to help preserve the
health of my hair or basically restore
the health of my hair when it has become
damaged and this is what I have been
doing lately because I had recently done
a Balayage hairstyle basically I
bleached my hair to a blonde color which
I later realized was a mistake I'm glad
that I did it because I tried it and now
I know but it did damage my hair and so
the way that I cut my hair really helped
to restore its Health to what it is
currently and so using this technique is
really what helped me restore it back to
Baseline
basically what I do is I grab my hair in
small pieces maybe about one centimeter
to a half an inch thick I put it in
between my second and third finger
and I begin to snip away at the ends
little by little beginning from the top
all the way down to the bottom this is
especially helpful for anybody that has
tons of split ends so I grab it at the
top
hold it in between my hands and with my
scissors I begin to pull it back down
and cut
little bits at a time until I reach the
bottom
this is definitely a very time consuming
haircut but it can help you preserve
length so when I want to reduce damage
and preserve length this is especially
helpful this is also the way that I tend
to cut on his hair because she loves it
long and she loves it loose but she also
loves it in her oatmeal and her
spaghetti and all over the place so it
tends to have a lot of damage and
because she likes it long what I ended
up doing is cutting her hair in this way
because I have dyed my hair I use a
purple shampoo the brand that I use is
pureology and I use both the shampoo and
the conditioner
but before I had dyed my hair the only
conditioner that I used was coconut oil
as a hair mask
and this is currently what I use when my
hair is getting a little too dry for
comfort as especially in these cold
Winters
the way that I use it is I basically
warm it in my hands and then massage it
all the way through my hair and my scalp
I take this as an opportunity for some
self-care by giving myself a scalp
massage
and who doesn't love a good scalp
after I'm finished and all of my hair is
covered I take out my husband's handy
dandy t-shirt because
I don't want to use my own
and I DIY a hair cap
by taking the arms of the shirt and
folding them around the back to tie a
knot in the front
I leave this on for about 30 minutes to
an hour before I shower and then I just
wash rinse and repeat like normal so now
I'll show you what I actually do when I
wash my hair and I wash my hair about
every third day or so
once I have washed my hair and gently
patted it dry with a towel there are
really only two products that I use in
my hair
the first would be olaplex number six
Bond smoother this is my anti-frizz
serum that I cannot go without I love
this thing
and the other would be a really good
Argan Oil my two favorites are Redken
all soft and olaplex number six but I do
not use both of them it just so happened
that I had been on the hunt for the
perfect one and I found two so I
alternate between them on this day we'll
use the Redken and you see that even
though they are a little bit on the
pricey end they last a really long time
I have had both of these for several
months and a little bit goes a long way
because I have long hair I use about one
and a half to two squirts of my
antifreeze serum and then about a dime
sized amount of the either Redken oil or
about five drops of the olaplex number
seven
and then I simply massage this into my
hands until it is all mixed in together
and I run it through my hair making sure
that it completely covers my hair once
my hair is evenly covered I then very
gently begin to brush my hair in order
to detangle it and I make sure to be
very very gentle because hair is prone
to damage when brushed When Wet
so what I do for this is I hold my hair
with one hand and I begin brushing it
starting at the ends and I proceed until
the rest of my hair is detangled
once it is done
I roll my hair into a very loose bun
usually I begin with a bun at the curve
of my neck
and then I basically leave it here for a
couple of hours until the top of my head
is dry
once the top of my head is dry then I
roll it at a bun at the very top of my
head and I basically leave it here
foreign
I also want to interject here for a
moment and talk a little bit about
headaches because I currently have one
so it's fresh on my mind at least for me
I can definitely tell a difference
between a scalp bake like from wearing a
high ponytail where your scalp just
hurts and the headache that's like I
feel right now and for me personally
I've noticed that my headaches tend to
have a pattern to them it's usually I'm
not eating well enough I'm not sleeping
or I'm stressing or I have inflammation
and typically they come around that time
of the month so at least for me I feel
like it's not necessarily the hair up
that causes the headache but so much as
I had a headache and then because I had
my hair up it just made it worse or it
made me more sensitive basically and I'm
definitely not saying that you can't get
a headache from having your hair up but
what I do if I am having a headache is
that I place my hair in a very loose bun
that's low basically like right around
here or I will place my hair in a very
very loose braid that starts at the top
of my head so that I'm not pulling on my
scalp or just making myself feel even
worse and if the headache is bad enough
such as when I was sick recently then
I'll just leave it loose and let it do
what it wants to do okay so this is me
after waking up never mind the horse
voice because I am sick today but still
I want to show you how it is that I wake
up with a good hair day even while I'm
sick
so I have my bun
that I raised up and basically I'm just
going to undo this
and when I put it up what it does is
that it makes it so that there's no
frizz but it also kind of curls it
naturally
it's hard to do it one-handed
and then I just basically Bring It
Forward and because I brushed it when it
was wet what it did is that it kind of
detangles it so that when I let it down
it's nice and soft and smooth and I put
the antifreeze serum so that means it's
nice and smooth and of course my argan
oil will never fail and look at that
it's just waking up I didn't curl it
didn't straighten it I didn't do
anything to it this is just morning hair
so this is how you wake up with a good
hair day
that's it for today's video I hope that
you have found it helpful so that you
can wake up to morning hair that you
love waking up to with little time and
effort so maybe you can ditch the hair
curler and the hair straightener and the
blow dryer and just get rid of them all
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so you won't
miss when I post a new video and if you
have any other recommendations of things
that you would like to see please let me
know in the comments down below and
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in the next one bye for now